Is not taker.
The.
How are you doing, Chester, Danny?
Wait.
Good.
Doing it.
It's been so long that we met. So, how have you been?
Okay.
Yeah.
Ohh.
All right.
Key.
Uhh...
Great.
What's on our agenda today?
Yep, agenda remains the same. We would discuss about Ray, how he's progressing, how he had been the past month. Yep. Before we go to Ray, I just wanted to know about Danny, how he is settling into the new role.
Mm.
Yeah, I'm having fun learning new things every day, getting up to speed on things, getting a good grasp over how things are happening and how we can improve.
That's great.
Kour.
That's great. Thank you so much. All right, so okay, let's quickly jump to our agenda regarding Ray. So I know just introduced Danny last month that he will be the new reporting manager for Ray. And even I was discussing this with Ray that how the past month had been, how he's interacting with.
the change of his reporting. So he's completely fine there, settling in good. And I think he had a connect with Danny as well. So things are going well from his perspective. So I wanted to know, Danny, from you first, how have you noticed him in the past month and what is your take?
Mhm.
Not bad. I mean, he's still relatively changing, getting used to working with me. But overall, no, I think his utilization is not bad. It definitely can improve. That's the one key performance indicator that we're probably going to be looking at moving forward. But yeah, we're just working on ways where we can get the team more efficient, kind of specializing on certain tasks. Like he's a T2, right? So we're getting him to do the backup checks, health checks.
In addition to more complex tickets.
Great. Any specific technology Danny Asperia connects with Ray that you have identified that you think he can be better trained on, or you foresee that maybe in upcoming weeks or months, you see that he would be required to work on such tickets?
I think just familiarizing with the environments of our clients, some of them are pretty unique, some of them are more standardized, so I think he's getting there more or less. He's slowly learning and, you know, the biggest thing probably would be the backup checks that the T2s do, that they help out our system. Some of the firmware updates are also looking at recently.
seeing what we can do to help out our essays and free up their time.
Thank you so much. Any other feedback or concerns, Danny, you have for Ray?
I think sometimes we all forget to kind of check on our tickets. So definitely during the day, I do go through and take a look to see if anyone gets stalled tickets to make sure they remember to check in. They remember to check in if a client has responded to make sure we try to ideally finish the ticket during the day, or if not, the next day.
Thank you.
All right, Chester, any input from your site?
No, not really, because I kind of haven't been really interacting from with way ever since Danny kind of joined in. So I will just follow his lead.
Sounds good.
Yeah.
All right. So another thing in terms of the feedback for Ray, I have Chester, your name listed as of yet for the POC, the recipient for the CSAT service. Do you want us to change it to Danny?
Mhm.
Yes, please.
Thank you.
All right. You're welcome. So, for the month of April, the CSATs were triggered under Chester, your name. So, I would appreciate if you could please take out some time and fill in the CSAT for Ray. And going forward, it will be sent to Danny. So, we'll keep you posted around...
Blake.
The.
The the service for rate.
Sounded.
Thank you. Second thing regarding the upcoming holiday, that's Victoria Day, which is on May 18th. I believe Ray is going to take an off on 18th.
Um...
I don't think we have anything.
Is U.S. not a holiday? U.S. is not a holiday, right?
For US, the holiday is on 25th, which is Memorial Day. And for Canada, it's 18th Victoria Day.
Oh wait, is it the entire, it's entire Canada, right? Not just the BC.
Ahh.
Must be. It's a federal, yeah, so it's in entire Canada. So yeah, it should be okay to take a Monday off.
If in case there are any changes to the plan, Chester, Danny, you can just reach out to me over email. And if you require him to work on 18th, I'll make the arrangement and he can take the compensation off in the upcoming weeks.
Yeah.
Great.
Right.
Thank you. Before I jump into the presentation deck, is there anything else, Chester, Danny, you want to share?
No.
Nope. I'm going to congratulate him on the AZ104, but other than that.
In it, yes, that's right.
Okay, with that being said, I'll really bring up my screen. Just give me a moment here.
I hope you can see my screen.
Yep.
Yeah.
Thank you. So welcome to our monthly business review, and the review duration is April 6th till May 1st. Starting with our agenda items, it remains the same. We have check-in, followed by the highlights of the account, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of the customer, way forward, and then recap.
So starting with how are things at this moment, we have already received good feedback for Ray. Thank you so much, Chester and Danny, for your support there.
Next is the highlights. These are the discussion points from my previous Connect where overall performance was positive. We did discuss about a few corrective actions that's regarding entering the billable and non-billable time that has to be categorized. So same thing was reinforced to Ray and he has implemented it.
Danny was introduced as a new lead for Ray, so this is something that we got to know in the previous Connect, and for the CSAT piece, so this is something we will keep. We decided to keep Chester, and going forward it will be.
Daddy.
Mmh.
Any questions so far?
Nope.
Kip.
Mm.
Alright, this is the action tracker where the bright gauge access and the Kip IPs for array that was spending, so...
Chester, I know we have been working on this for quite some time. Do we see any date that we might be able to accomplish it?
I think August is still looking.
Like a possible date, we have a lot of team right now, a lot of people on the team across other business units that are working on getting us integrated into the national platform, so...
Things are.
Progressing, so.
For now, yeah, that will, or we're gonna have to keep it at August as the target date.
Okay.
Okay, I'll update it. Target date to be August.
Right, these were the recommended K.P.I.'s, so Sarbjeet has spoke about this already when we have discussed it too, so I'll skip this.
Next is performance analysis for Ray. This is his utilization starting April 6th till May 1st with average billable for Ray stands at 56% and non-billable at 18%. So this is the calculation that we have made out of
Yes.
Eight hours per day, however, as per the Connect Base Management calculation, the utilization had been seventy-five percent and above, so I know in that tool the calculations setup is slightly different than the way we have done the calculation, so...
Just wanted to know, Danny, how do you see these numbers? Are they matching with the one that you have or do you have any questions on this?
I see him in the 70s, but still, still below what we had, we want for the target, but yeah, definitely not as low as what you guys are showing.
Correct. So what we have done is out of nine hours of his shift, one is for his break. Out of those eight hours, we have captured how many hours he entered into the billable site. So if in eight hours he entered 6 hours as the billable, so his utilization billable would be 75%.
Mhm.
25 would be non-billable for that particular day. This is how the whole calculation is based on, but I think in ConnectWise Management, out of the time that he entered into the ticket throughout the day, how much billable was the time that he entered overall in the tickets. So I think this is how
The calculation is done in manage, and the difference between our calculation and ConnectWise Manager's calculation.
Key.
Yep.
But let me know if you have any questions there or any concerns, please feel free.
Yeah. Do we have a plan for him to move forward to increase? Like either way we look at it, it's definitely a little bit low. What is your thoughts on how do we can close that gap?
I think we can get him to work on more tickets because there are few ticket entries where I know the task that he's doing is sort of repeated, so he knows what he needs to do. Although the tickets that he's working on are relatively more as compared to the time that he's entering.
But if he's getting technologies, some tickets from new technologies or different technologies to work on, he would do some research RMT and possibly that will increase his pay level too.
Okay, sounds good.
Yep.
So is he not charging the research in as a billable time entry or?
No, no, no. So the ticket that he's working as of yet, they are like, he knows like what to do. So the research time is very limited on those tickets. Or no, yes.
Mhm.
Sure.
Yeah.
Thank you. Next is the tickets closure rate for Ray. So, as I was saying, that the target is like 8 tickets per day for the engineer. Ray had been surpassing the targets every week. In first week, he closed 53, then 59, 44, and...
the 37 tickets in these weeks. Overall, it's 193 tickets and the technologies that I have listed as Office 365, SharePoint, Service Support, AR alerts and escalation tickets. This is the overall, the ticket category, the technology that he worked on.
On the best month.
Any questions?
Pretty clear.
Thank you.
Okay, next is way forward. This is where AZ104 certification is completed by Ray. So thank you so much for that. I have a quick question. This is something I guess Ray was telling me that this is Chester, you told him to complete the certification that.
And you would be, you would you want to sponsor the certification for Ray?
So the exam cost, yeah, we can cover.
Okay, yep. Thank you so much. So I'll get this checked internally.
Yeah.
Kour.
Thank you. Next is regarding maintain strong focus on client infrastructure and core operational processes. So this is being done already, improved utilization by aligning work more closely with active demand and priorities. So as we have discussed, we will work towards getting his utilization numbers more.
and ensure accurate and time capture and agreement alignment to strengthen reporting and transparency. This is what we have cascaded in the previous connect to array and he has already implemented it.
Yeah.
Okay, this is Bill IT Live, so Sarbjeet, what do you?
Thank you. Thank you, Ashish. Thank you, Chester, Danny, for sharing the feedback once again. And Danny, just one thing I'd like to add in before we move into the build it live. So in case if you think that we have plenty of tasks available on the board or whether it's documentation, wherever you think you would like to utilize Chester to improve his billable utilization,
OK.
Feel free to do so, as we are managing the board, or so if you see something which is pending, or feel free to assign those tasks to Jester, so to Ray, so that he will feel challenged and feel occupied too. Coming on to the Build It Live, that's our annual event, so this is the 8th one in the row.
So every year we take our partners to different off-sites and then this is more of an MSP industry event. As you can stop the screen sharing, I'll take them to the website so that we can share more details. This is happening in the month of August, August 3rd to 5th. That's for three days.
This is happening in New Jersey, Hyatt Regency. Talking about the attendees, we have more than 550 attendees over here, 70 plus channel influencers. We have already created tools, templates, processes, which you can straight away and build into your system. Habib is already coming from MSP Corp, Jester, so feel free to let us know. I will also be sending out the information to Karine to his.
and rest of the team. I just wanted to make sure that you all have the details available. So the focus as of now, we are monetizing AI for your business growth in terms of sustaining the intelligent innovations which has been already created, the ABIT.
That can be, and then the focus will also be on the AI leadership strategy, and so this is talking about the speaker lineup along with different MSPs. We will have John C. Maxwell, Dan Sullivan that will be coming in here, and then talking about...
since the after hours event that's happening on the third day, that's on August 5th. This is the New York Stock Exchange where the team event will be great gets B team. And so.
Talking about the pricing for this ticket, as of now for our partner specifically, we have BOGO offer available with one ticket, you will be getting another ticket free of cost. So that's 1495. That's the current price of the ticket. In case if more members will be coming in from the team, we would love to have you there. So feel free to let me know. I can definitely check out for
a group pass or something that's required. I'll ping you the code, the website link, both, and rest if there is any clarity required, let's say in terms of booking the rooms or the flights, you can always let us know. So I have sent you the link as well.
In addition to this, let me forward the code.
Just a second. Any questions on the event?
Mr. Danny.
Nope.
No.
Okay, do you let me just do one quick second. I would love to share the agenda as well so that you can know what's in it for you. So on August 2nd, we do have an event specifically our mastermind peer group. So this is the event agenda for the next three days. The focus, as I mentioned earlier.
We have different breakout sessions for the leadership team, for operations, for the sales team, marketing team. So this is the agenda for the first day, then this is for second day. We have plenty of breakout sessions focusing on the four major structures, AI, leadership, operations, then growth and sales, and then simultaneously on August 5th.
This will be primarily focused on AI accelerator, the implementations, the innovations, which has already been done within the organization. So feel free to utilize that. Next, we just a text away. If there is any clarity required, feel free to ping me on Teams. I would love to get on a call with you.
Cool.
Thank you. Thanks, Ashish. Over to you.
Thank you, Sarbjeet. Thank you so much, Esther and Danny. Before we call it a meeting, is there anything else that you want to share?
Um...
Just one, just heard.
looking at time entries for Ray. So if he's going to be using charge codes, we need some details of what.
The purpose of the charge code was used for.
Um...
So...
Can you share the screen tester?
To share? No, I'm just gonna share my screen, so I'll give you an example here: this is last week.
So we have training and assistance. You know, so 4 hours went on training and assistance. If I look, there's no details on this.
No.
Blake.
This one has no details, and then this one, yeah, assisting another tag.
So, because we want to be able to document where the hours are going, right? So we can't have like an hour or 4 hours missing and we don't know what happened.
Kour.
Mhm.
Exactly, yeah.
Got it.
Yeah, exactly.
Can you please work it along with Ray?
I will.
Thank you.
Okay.
Anything else, Chester, which you think that needs to be taken care of?
All right.
I know, that's all for me.
Thank you, Danny. Anything else from your end?
Okay.
Nope, that was good. I just touched base on that piece on the numbers that Chester brought up. Yeah, we're in the 70s, right? So I don't know why you guys are showing 50s. I'm wondering why there's a discrepancy.
Oh, it's the calculation. So they do an eight-hour calculation where ConnectWise on our side does a nine-hour.
Key.
Exactly. So we are excluding all the breaks.
Ah, I see.
Yes.
Yeah.
Yep.
So it's only the productive time which we are focusing on.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
Okay, thank you for that.
That's right. Yep, you're welcome. But we'll still work with Ray to ensure that his billable numbers go up. And Chester, as you mentioned, the description of the non-billable side, the training side that he's putting in, it has to be documented.
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, thank you for that.
Yeah, great. Thank you. Thank you, guys.
All right. Thank you so much guys for your time. We'll see you next month. Bye.
Thanks, guys. Take care. Goodbye.
Thank you, Chester. Thank you, Danny. Have a good one. Take care.
OK, bye-bye.